[Música]
seguro que la mayoría de la comunidad de
visualpolitik vivís en países donde la
presidencia cambia frecuentemente de
manos de forma pacífica normalmente cada
4 años sin embargo todos sabemos que
esto no es algo habitual en el mundo y
seguramente sean los africanos quienes
mejor lo saben ahí tenemos el ejemplo de
teodorobian El dictador de Guinea
ecuatorial que lleva más de 40 años en
el poder pero no hoy o bien no va a ser
el protagonista de nuestro vídeo hoy nos
trasladamos hasta el este de África para
visitar a otro dictador que lleva ya más
de 37 años en el poder hablamos de
yogueri Muse Beni el presidente de
uganda quizás muchos de vosotros no le
conozcáis pero ya os adelanto que
hablamos de un tipo que en los últimos
años ha sido muy señalado por los medios
de comunicación y no precisamente para
bien Estados Unidos exigió al presidente
de uganda llover y Muse Beni que no
ratifique el proyecto de ley aprobado
por el parlamento que condena a 10 años
de cárcel a homosexuales o aquellos que
se identifiquen con el archivo lgtbiq
efectivamente la Cruzada del gobierno
islandés contra la comunidad lgbt ha
vuelto a tomar impulso Claro que la
represión no se dirige solo hacia este
grupo sino que también se dirige a
cualquiera que se atreva a enfrentarse a
esta horrible dictadura pero no se
suponía acaso que África es el paraíso
de los golpes de estado y las
revoluciones de todo tipo como ha
logrado este señor durar tanto tiempo en
el poder pues evidentemente la represión
la represión Ultra brutal ha sido uno de
los ingredientes de esta larga vida pero
a diferencia de otros dictadores el
señor museo tiene otra arma las reformas
económicas
[Música]
habéis oído bien desde el comienzo de su
presidencia uganda se ha convertido en
una de las economías más estables y con
mayor crecimiento de toda África sí es
cierto jugando sigue siendo un país
pobre muy pobre y Su economía sigue
basándose en gran parte en la
agricultura pero aún así se han logrado
Muchos avances avances Por cierto
aplaudidos por prácticamente todos los
organismos internacionales sin embargo
ya sabéis que con este tipo de
dictaduras siempre suele haber algo de
gato encerrado por eso aquí hoy en
visualpolitik nos hemos hecho unas
cuantas preguntas realmente podemos
hablar del despegue de uganda están
mejorando de verdad las condiciones de
vida de los ugandeses con museo que ha
hecho Exactamente para mantenerse tanto
tiempo en el poder y quizás la pregunta
más sorprendente de todas podría Ruanda
que es toda una potencia regional
emergente provocar su derrocamiento hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
uganda de dictador en dictador
a estas alturas los que seáis veteranos
seguidores de visualpolitik ya sabréis
que hay países que nunca han
experimentado una transición pacífica
del poder Pues bien uganda Podría
encajar perfectamente en esta
descripción y es que veréis tras más de
70 años siendo un protectorado uganda se
independizó de Reino Unido en el año
1962 con la independencia recién
estrenada uganda escogió como presidente
a Milton o bote que era un líder de
claras tendencias socialistas de repente
el gobierno nacionalizó la empresa
petrolera las minas de cobre de quilembe
que era una de las grandes Industrias
del país y el servicio de autobuses
conclusión el capital internacional se
marchó Pero esto no es lo peor de todo
porque como es Norma habitual en África
los problemas étnicos No tardaron en
aparecer tras la independencia y el
bueno de ovotec decidió redactar una
nueva constitución que le nombraba
presidente permanente y abolian los
reinos étnicos del país Así es como vote
se convirtió en el primer tirano de
Logan independiente pero tranquilos
porque no fue ni el único ni el peor en
cualquier caso duró poco porque en 1961
perdió el poder tras un golpe de estado
y el nuevo líder prometía unificar el
país y arreglar la economía sin embargo
todo se quedó en promesas estamos
hablando de ID amintada con ideamin todo
fue a peor pero muy a peor
Y por qué os decimos esto pues veréis
para empezar no solo persiguió a los
trabajadores cualificados sino que
incluso
echó aparte a la élite empresarial china
Porque muchos consideraban que se estaba
aprovechando de los ugandeses conclusión
los establecimientos de los chinos que
se marcharon fueron entregados a
oficiales del ejército que ni siquiera
sabían Cómo manejar un negocio y al
final la gran mayoría quebraron Mientras
tanto y día min subía el presupuesto
militar como si no hubiera mañana a la
vez que continuaba las nacionalizaciones
que había empezado el socialista o bote
el problema que no había dinero solución
de tirano de manual darle a la máquina
de imprimir billetes creando una
inflación galopante pero esperad un
momento porque esto es solo la economía
la verdadera sombra de idea fue la
represión brutal de su población se
estima que entre 80.000 y 500.000
personas fueron asesinadas durante su
dictadura Al final a mí no llegó a ser
el sueño que muchos esperaban sino que
fue su pesadilla por eso en 1979 después
de que tanzania invadiera uganda huyó
del país su régimen de terror había
acabado no obstante las cosas no fueron
a mejor porque a vos te volvi ó y
continuó su desastrosa presidencia pero
esta vez con más inflación más represión
y una mayor oposición de las guerrillas
y como era de esperar o vote volvió a
ser depuesto en 1965 y así es como en
tres escena nuestro protagonista de hoy
musebén y al igual que obote después de
la Independencia de uganda e iría minda
dada en 1971 musa Beni también se erigió
en la nueva esperanza de uganda Y diréis
qué ha hecho este hombre pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
el nuevo Mesías hogandés
es una de esas figuras políticas de las
que se puede hacer fácilmente una
película fijaos pero viene de una
familia campesina se exilió durante el
régimen de Amin y formó el frente de
salvación nacional que al final ayudó a
derrocar al sacramento dictador durante
la segunda etapa de bote formó otra
guerrilla hasta convertirse en
presidente en 1986 lo sé es una carrera
política un poco rara porque está basada
en las armas más que en las elecciones
pero que esperáis es uganda en cualquier
caso durante años museoveri Fue alabado
por la comunidad internacional
durante mucho tiempo Muse Beni fue
considerado un ejemplo a seguir ya fuera
por su éxito en la lucha contra el sida
en el país como por introducir profundas
reformas económicas el líder ugandés
pronto se granjeó el apoyo de Estados
Unidos y la Unión Europea la eliminación
de los controles de precios la reducción
del peso del sector público el freno a
la emisión monetaria y las facilidades
para invertir lograron mejorar y mucho
la situación económica la tasa de
inflación fue un buen ejemplo de cómo
cambiaron las cosas Además desde que
llegó al poder el pib de uganda se ha
multiplicado por 10
pero como os podéis imaginar Esta no es
toda la historia porque los observadores
Internacionales han denunciado numerosas
veces que museo ha amañado todas las
elecciones en las que se ha presentado
desde 1996 lo dicho este hombre tiene
una forma un poco rara de entender la
política además ha reformado la
Constitución a su gusto para poder
mantenerse indefinidamente en el poder y
no hablamos ya de la corrupción
galopante o de su obsesión con perseguir
a la comunidad lgbt que comenzó en 2009
sin embargo si tuviéramos que destacar
el mayor fracaso de museo Beni este
sería seguramente la pobreza sí es
cierto el porcentaje de población que
vive con menos de un dólar al día ha
caído del 56% a principios de los 90 al
20% actual pero aún así siguen siendo
unas cifras devastadoras uganda es un
país muy pobre la mayoría de la
población es pobre y una quinta parte de
sus 47 millones de habitantes vive en la
más absoluta y extrema pobreza que es lo
que explica Que todavía nos encontremos
con noticias como estas
15 de junio de 2022 El hambre mata a los
niños en un rincón olvidado de uganda
más de 91.000 niños sufren desnutrición
aguda en una de las regiones más pobres
de uganda para que os hagáis una idea
según el programa mundial de elementos
de la ONU casi el 30% de todos los niños
menores de 5 años de uganda están
atrofiados por la desnutrición terrible
no obstante la pobreza y la hambruna son
solo la Cumbre de la montaña de los
problemas a los que se enfrenta Muse
Beni Los Rebeldes están al acecho y un
vecino incómodo
le está obligando a mantenerse en una
alerta constante de quienes estamos
hablando pues atentos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
guerrillas y malos vecinos
[Música]
cuando hablamos del estado islámico el
daes seguro que muchos pensáis
automáticamente en Oriente medio verdad
Bueno si sois veteranos seguidores de
visualpolitik ya sabéis que el daes
también está muy presente en África
seguro que a todos os suena poco harán
verdad pues es una organización que
forma parte del estado islámico pero ojo
no solo hablamos de poco harán que actúa
sobre todo en Nigeria sino del llamado
estado islámico de la provincia de
África Central Aunque Bueno en realidad
la mayoría no lo conoce por ese nombre
sino por el nombre de fuerzas
democráticas aliadas fda
[Música]
las fda surgieron en uganda en 1995 como
un movimiento militante islamista que
tenía como principal objetivo derrocar a
Muse Beni no obstante después de que el
ejército ugandés lograra acorralarles se
expandió por los países vecinos
especialmente a la República democrática
del Congo desde entonces los ataques se
concentraron en la República democrática
del Congo y en 2017 su líder musa balucu
juró al estado islámico
a partir de ese momento el fda se volvió
cada vez más violento de hecho entre
2017 y 2021 el 69% de todos los
asesinatos a civiles en el Congo fueron
atribuidos a esta organización para que
os hagáis una idea solo en 2021 mataron
a 1.300 civiles un 50% más que en 2020
no obstante en 2021 el fda dejó de
operar solamente en la República
democrática del Congo y después de años
sin hacerlo volvió a tentar en la propio
uganda entre octubre y noviembre de ese
año se sucedieron varios atentados con
bomba que se cobraron en la vida de al
menos 10 personas y que forzaron el
cierre temporal del parlamento Irlandés
Entonces el ejército de mut Seven y se
puso manos a la obra y como consecuencia
nos encontramos con noticias como estas
el ejército bugatés informa de que ha
matado a 11 Rebeldes de las fda que
entraron en el país desde el Congo
operación conjunta de la República
democrática del Congo y uganda para
liberar a 100 Rehenes del grupo fda son
tan solo dos ejemplos Pero y si os
dijera que el fda no es el grupo más
problemático para museo Y si os dijera
que hay otro grupo que supone una
amenaza mucho mayor y que además está
financiado por un vecino suyo
efectivamente mis queridos amigos de la
comunidad de visualpolitik ese es el
caso del movimiento 23 de marzo o m23 el
m23 se formó en 2012 en la República
democrática del Congo por soldados
desencantados con el gobierno de este
país y os preguntaréis qué tiene que
haber entonces este grupo Rebelde con
uganda Pues veréis los soldados
congoleños son de la etnia tutsi sí
Exacto los mismos tutsis que sufrieron
un genocidio en Ruanda y sí los mismos
tutsis a los que pertenece el actual
presidente de Ruanda Paul kagame vale
esto en principio no nos dice nada pero
igual esta noticia ya os da una pista
expertos de la ONU las fuerzas ruandesas
operan con Los Rebeldes del m-23 en el
Congo Exacto Ruanda está apoyando al
m-23 en la República democrática del
Congo porque agame que tampoco es
precisamente un líder democrático ha
estado enviando armas desde kigali que
es la capital de Ruanda a este grupo y
diréis Pero esto que tiene que ver con
uganda pues veréis es cierto que al
menos por el momento el m-23 no ha
atentado en territorio islandés Pero lo
que sí está haciendo es frenar los
proyectos de Muse Beni en el Congo por
ejemplo uganda y el Congo llegaron a un
acuerdo para que los giganteses
construyeran una carretera juntos esta
carretera evitaría que muchas mercancías
tuvieran que cruzar por el territorio
ruandés conclusión que haga me apoyó al
m-23 para que interrumpiera en el
proyecto de hecho tomaron la ciudad
fronteriza de buona gana en el Congo y
obligaron a todos los trabajadores
jugandeses a retirarse recordad además
que el Congo tiene un montón de recursos
naturales que se utilizan por ejemplo
para hacer móviles el m-23 es un arma
que permite que Ruanda pudiera
controlarlos Y eso significa más poder
para Ruanda que ya sabéis que cada vez
tiene más influencia en la región pese a
ser un país muy pequeño por ejemplo el
m-23 ha llegado a tomar la ciudad de
rubaya que es una de las ciudades más
importantes del continente para la
extracción del Preciado coltán ya sabéis
que el coltán es la roca de la que se
saca el tantalio que se utiliza para
muchos componentes que usamos en los
teléfonos móviles por ejemplo Por cierto
que en visualpolitik tenemos un vídeo
dedicado en exclusiva a minería del
coltán en el Congo pero siendo en estos
en verdad los grupos Rebeldes no son el
mayor de los problemas de Muse Beni
sabéis que es lo que realmente más teme
este hombre porque realmente podría
acabar con su dictadura Pues ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver
un país al límite
[Música]
después de todo lo que hemos visto está
muy claro que las élites políticas en
uganda se llaman fatal con las élites
políticas de la vecina Ruanda verdad
pues no del todo porque hay una persona
que se lleva fenomenal con el gobierno
de kigali capital de Ruanda de quién
estamos hablando pues nada más y nada
menos que del hijo mayor de Muse Beni
habéis oído bien el general mujozi que
inervaba es el hijo mayor y posible
sucesor de museo ha visitado Ruanda
numerosas veces considera que Paul
kagame es su tío y Los Rebeldes del m-23
sus hermanos vamos que es como el hijo
rebelde no solo ha criticado al partido
de su padre en varias ocasiones incluso
ha llegado a ignorar órdenes del
ejército recordáis cuando os decía que
en el m-23 tomó la ciudad de buona gana
Pues bien este general ignoró las
órdenes del ejército que decían que
estuvieran en máxima alerta en la
frontera en cualquier caso lo más
interesante de todo esto es que el hijo
de museoni es un buen reflejo del
hartazgo que la sociedad holandesa tiene
hacia la dictadura que les gobierna un
hartazgo que se vio mejor que nunca en
las últimas
del año 2021 el lugar donde es Bobby
wine convoca protestas contra los
resultados electorales las elecciones de
2021 fueron las más violentas en años
por qué Pues porque los jóvenes de las
ciudades sobre todo en la capital
campana que apoyan mayoritariamente a la
oposición volvieron a sentirse
profundamente defraudados con el robo
electoral
[Música]
ansiosos de un cambio que mejore sus
oportunidades de empleo y su situación
económica cuando el popular líder de la
oposición Bobby wine fue detenido
durante su campaña política y puesto en
arresto domiciliario durante dos semanas
la juventud salió a las calles a
protestar y cuando se detectó un nuevo
fraude electoral en favor de Muse Beni
volvieron a las andadas por supuesto en
ambos casos el régimen de Muse Beni e
teme una particular Primavera árabe en
el país reprimió con dureza las
protestas una práctica habitual durante
su régimen de hecho durante las
protestas por el arresto de Bobby wine
el ejército asesinó a 54 personas y
después del fraude electoral la
oposición denunció la desaparición de
243 personas más
querida comunidad de visualpolitik ya lo
veis uganda no consigue salir de este
bucle de dictadores locos que prometen
mucho pero que a la hora de la verdad
resultan un insoportable toda una
pesadilla para los holandeses ya pasó
con o bote y con y día mimín primero y
ahora museo viniste siguiendo el mismo
camino Cada vez más corrupto cada vez
más represivo y cada vez más incapaz de
superar los problemas de uganda entre la
pobreza el hambre y la ausencia de una
verdadera democracia el mayor problema
de museo no son ni los grupos Rebeldes
de Ruanda sino las propias condiciones
que ha creado para perpetuarse en el
poder La pregunta es terminará Muse
Benny como sus dos predecesores
conseguiré evitar tener el mismo destino
que vote y Amin logrará su hijo hacerse
con el poder e impulsar grandes cambios
en el país solo el tiempo podrá
respondernos a estas preguntas de
momento podéis dejarme vuestras
respuestas en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal y dándole a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones Ah y no olvidéis que
tenemos.com nuestro newsletter gratuita
Y si os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a
like y nos vemos en el próximo un saludo
y hasta pronto
[Música]